Mit Phosphat und Hitze werden bei Sebastian
Lege Fleischreste zu Kochschinken.
"Und wir machen jetzt mal
Kochschinken so günstig wie es geht."
Und das ist alles regelkonform, auch
wenn die Metzgerin da verzweifelt.
"Sünde, was wir hier gerade machen. Das ist Sünde!"
Was im günstigen Kochschinken
aus dem Supermarkt steckt,
zeigt euch Sebastian Lege.
Saftig und aus einem Stück geschnitten -
das macht einen leckeren Kochschinken aus.
Metzgermeisterin Katharina Koch
weiß, was man dazu benötigt.
KATHARINA: "Das ist die Keule vom Schwein."
Man kann auch ruhig Pobacke sagen.
"Die werden wir jetzt auslösen und
den Kochschinken daraus zubereiten."
Wasser und Pökelsalz bringt die Würze und Farbe in den Schinken.
Mehr braucht die Metzgerin nicht.
Zwei Tage bleibt die Keule in der Lake,
danach wird sie übrigens nicht gekocht,
wie der Name vermuten lässt.
Vielmehr wird der Schinken für vier
Stunden bei 65 Grad schonend gegart.
So wird er am zartesten.
Diesen Leckerbissen möchte sich Sebastian
Lege natürlich nicht entgehen lassen.
SEBASTIAN: "Richtig lecker!"
KATHARINA: "Vielen Dank!"
SEBASTIAN: "Aber auch viel Zeit kostet auch sein Geld."
Das stimmt! Bei Katharina Koch  kostet
Kochschinken gut zwei Euro pro 100 Gramm.
Sebastian hat einen anderen Plan.
SEBASTIAN: "Und wir machen jetzt mal
Kochschinken so günstig, wie es geht."
Das heißt Maschinen, Maschinen!
Und auch bei den Zutaten hat Sebastian
die Tricks der Industrie im Köcher.
Ein großes Einzelstück braucht Sebastian nicht.
Er setzt auf kleine Fleischreste.
SEBASTIAN: "Die Stücke dürfen nicht
kleiner sein als 250 Gramm,
weil sonst dürften wir es nicht
mehr  Kochschinken nennen."
Die Vorschriften hat sich die
Branche selber gegeben.
Also alles regelkonform. Sorry, Katharina!
KATHARINA: "Sünde, was wir
hier gerade machen, Sünde!"
"Tiefste Sünde!"
Auch Sebastian spritzt Pökelsalzlake in das
Fleisch, allerdings deutlich mehr als die Metzgerin.
Und das bleibt nicht das einzige Hilfsmittel.
In einer Trommel werden die Fleischstücke
mit ordentlich Phosphat vermischt.
Die Chemikalie sorgt dafür, dass die
Reste gut aneinander kleben.
Aus vielen kleinen Resten wird
so ein schöner Schinken.
SEBASTIAN:  "So alle Zaubertricks sind vereint."
"Ich würde sagen: Karussell gleich los!"
Nur zwölf Stunden in der Chemie-Trommel
und Sebastians Fleisch ist weich.
Katharinas Schinken brauchte
dafür mehrere Tage.
SEBASTIAN: "Ja, reicht, oder?"
"Schalten wir aus!"
"Schauen wir mal rein, was
wir da so fabriziert haben."
Wirklich lecker, Sebastian...
Nun muss die Fleischmasse nur
noch abgefüllt und gegart werden.
Dafür reicht ein Plastikschlauch.
Sind mit dem Ergebnis alle zufrieden?
SEBASTIAN: "Das sieht doch schon mal ganz gut aus."
KATHARINA: "Na ja..."
"Sieht nicht nach einem Schinken aus."
SEBASTIAN: "Na ja, wenn er später aufgeschnitten ist und auf dem Brötchen liegt..."
Ja - und genau das ist das Problem!
Der Trick funktioniert.
Unterschiede im Fleisch sind für
uns fast nicht erkennbar.
Ob Marke oder No-Name - die Hersteller
müssen auf ihren Verpackungen
nicht angeben, wenn der Kochschinken aus
mehreren Teilen zusammengesetzt wurde.
Packt man den Schinken auf den Leuchttisch,
sind die einzelnen Fleischteile klar zu erkennen.
Seid ihr beim Einkaufen ohne Leuchttisch unterwegs,
achtet auf die E-Nr. 450, 451 und 452.
Das sind Phosphate.
Wer die verwendet, muss die
auch als Zutat kennzeichnen.
Und Sebastian hat noch einen handfesten
Tipp, wie man dem Schwindel auch zu Hause
auf die Schliche kommt.
SEBASTIAN: "So, liebe Freunde!
Augen auf beim Schinkenkauf!"
"Achtet darauf, dass die Fasern gleichmäßig
laufen und nicht wie Navigationssysteme
nach links und rechts zeigen. Dann ist er
nur zusammen gewürfelt."
"Qualität kostet, dann schmeckt's auch!"
Noch mehr Tricks, Checks und Duelle
aus der Welt der Lebensmittel
findet ihr auf unserem
Kanal ZDFbesseresser!